the state of New York has a long
tradition of upholding the rights
granted to others from other states and
also from foreign jurisdictions the
state of New York has a long history of
granting marriage rights where New York
does not have such rights on our own
books for example common-law marriages
they exist in other states they do not
exist in New York we have a time held
and time-tested tradition of honoring
those marital rights same-sex marriages
marriage equality now in two of the
state's would come under the ambit of
that interpretation of the law we would
extend to people who were married in
other states whether of opposite sex or
of the same sex the same equal
opportunities in New York as we have
granted those marriages traditionally
that existed in other states by law or
in foreign jurisdictions by witness and
so one februari first of 2008 we reached
an appellate court decision in the
fourth department in the case of
Martinez vs monroe county this would
grant though would uphold those same
rights here in New York on May
fourteenth the day before the Supreme
Court of California granted marriage
equality in that state in New York 24
hours earlier I directed through my
counsel David Nocenti the counsels of
the agencies of our government to bring
back reports to all of us on june
thirtieth demonstrating any possible
conflicts such that we can be in
compliance with the law and that is how
we have addressed this issue so as to
avoid any lawsuits so as to avoid
discrimination so as to try to maintain
the same laws that have existed in New
York for decades
any questions exactly that New York is
working toward conjoining same-sex
marriage licenses that New York
recognizes as our federal constitution
mandates that we would uphold the rights
granted to individuals by other states
that's right we had not taken the action
to notify the agencies we wanted to make
sure that in terms of the implementation
that if there were any difficulties in
interpretation that we had a chance to
review it and we asked the agency's
report back so in many respects the
existence of this law has existed for a
very long time
can you answer critics who say that what
you are doing is an end run around the
legislature what this bill died last
year in state Senate this is not an end
run around the legislature if the
legislature wanted to take an action it
could the legislature has not provided
for marriage equality here in New York
I'm an advocate for it but that's not
the reason that I came to this
conclusion I am taking the same approach
that this state always has with respect
to out of state or out of four marriages
conducted and foreign governments being
recognized here in the state of New York
I'm following the law as it always has
existed and I would suggest it if they
went back and read the law that they
would come to a different interpretation
themselves even if they'd agree disagree
with the concept of marriage equality
they would have to understand that i
have not interpreted this law any
differently what I'm trying to do is to
accommodate the fact that if I didn't
take this action I would leave this
state open to lawsuits I would leave the
state treasury all open to monetary
damages and I would be discriminating
against individuals who are coming here
from other jurisdictions who will allow
that right when it was common law
marriages and other types of marriages
and now are suddenly being denied the
right and the court decision on this
matter has been unanimous and now we
have an appellate court decision and the
appeal was dismissed by the New York
State Court of Appeal so I am I think
well buttress in terms of the legal
interpretation and I think that perhaps
the critics should get a little better
informed
I'm not it was transparent it was it was
a in in no way our attempt to hide it
from anyone just took you all that long
to read it well not necessarily any
state a number of states have passed
Defense of Marriage acts so therefore
they have already acted on their own to
deny that opportunity New York is not
one of those states and so therefore
there is no legislative edict that is
preventing me from taking this action it
is actually the correct action because
it will bring our agencies in compliance
with human beings who have gotten
married and now just want the rights
that married couples have the right to
visit a spouse in a hospital the right
of intestacy the right to pass a license
after the death of a spouse the right to
be able to share in the cost of
prescription drug medication the right
to be counseled if your spouse is
injured or killed by a criminal justice
agency that's what we actually counted i
believe over 1100 different rights that
domestic partners would not have because
they're not married and that's why many
of us are in favor of marriage equality
and I'm one of them but that is not the
issue that compels me to send this
memorandum around to the agencies we are
trying to be in compliance with the laws
of the state of a have already existed
a lot of talk about your relationship
have you discussed this issue
he's coming here this afternoon on
another matter to visit me i'm sure
we'll have a conversation about it
before he leaves i'm trying to persuade
him i saw him yesterday and I haven't
been able to persuade him as yet but
it's an election year maybe the public
will jurisdictions and these same-sex
marriages would be illegal in those
jurisdictions what's the difference
what's the change yes it absolutely
would the only change here is that some
of the actions that the agencies take
involve some interpretation of federal
law and there is no federal statute on
this issue and so that's just an example
of where we just asked our agencies if
you see a problem please report back to
us by Monday June thirtieth and that's
what they're doing otherwise it was
really just an attempt to make life a
little easier for people who have gotten
married out of state and a and are
coming to New York
it doesn't change anything Cuffy couples
married outside of state will be
extended those same rights in New York
as we always have couples who are now
same-sex couples who are marriage out of
state will be given that same
opportunity by New York know they would
denied several all of the issues I was
talking about are things you can't get
from domestic partnership and it's the
reason that people who've lived together
for a number of years would like to be
married they've had the problem of a you
can't bury the spouse because the
spouses family comes in and buries him
you can't visit the spouse in the
hospital and people with family members
of the spell so they might not even have
been talking to for a number of years
get to come to the hospital and you
don't the two of you own a store
together one of you dies the license
doesn't pass to the partner because
domestic partners don't have that
opportunity there eleven or twelve
hundred of them on the books this is why
people who live together for a long time
would like to be married and as far as
I'm concerned I think it's beautiful I
think it's fine I think regardless of
the tenants of the religion of some and
the belief of some it is something that
our government should allow for people
and it may be misunderstood in this
generation but still as a government we
have to recognize that we're rights have
been granted in other states as part of
what our federal constitution was about
when it was enacted in ratified in 1787
that the states would respect other
states rights
no they're not they were not legal
because New York State does not have a
marriage equality statute actually my
fear was that it wouldn't stand up to
lawsuits that would be coming down in
other words if you have a valid marriage
license and you're in New York all of
the court actions that have been taken
has shown that we as a state would be
liable if we did not take this action in
other words we can't draw a distinction
between who's on the marriage license
we've been respecting these common law
licenses for many many years we don't
anticipate any cost aspect to the state
agencies however what we asked the state
agencies to report back in June is to
anything that would arise from this
implementation that would be a thought
to be important would be reported back
to us but least of which would be cost
there would be no effect on the private
sector at all not not to this point
excuse me
well I already have and and that's my
intention but I don't want that to be
confused with the fact that this is my
interpretation of the law as it stands
right now this is not any change that I
think needs to be made and this is why
I'm not making an end around anybody and
some of those busy legislators who think
I'm doing an end-around maybe they
should go into the legislature and
actually work on something
you